السوريه اسماعيل العبد الله اسماعيل
الاستجابه لهذه الكارثه حتى الساعه كيف
تبدو
منذ وصول منذ مشاهدهنا وصولنا نداءات
بوجود ابني بسبب الزلزال الذي ضرب شبابها
كل فرق الدفاع المدني كل فرقنا استجابت
لكل مواقع
يلي تعرضت
اللي تعرضت وكان في عالقين تحت الانقاض كل
فرقنا موجوده في الميدان لكن كما ذكرتم في
التقرير الرق على الجغرافيه كبيره وكون في
كل قريه وفي كل مدينه هناك ابنيه سقطت
وسقطت على رؤوس ساكنيها بسبب زلزال كل
معداتنا وكل المتطوعين الموجودين
الموجودين في الدفاع المدني السوري الان
يعملون بكامل طاقتهم للاستجابه
ولمساعده الناس الى الان اكثر من 140 شهيد
سقط خلال سقط بسبب هذا الزلزال واكثر من
300 جريح كل هذا
هذه الاحصائيه طبعا اوليه
احصائيه اوليه ممكن ان ترتفع باي وقت ممكن
لحظه الكلام ترتفع بسبب وجود عوائل كامله
عوائل كامله تحت الانقاذ نحن كمؤسسه
في عموم شمال غرب سوريا في شمال غرب سوريا
كل المناطق استجبنا الى الان سجلنا اكثر
من 140 قتيل بسبب 140 شهيد بسبب بسبب
الزلزال
طيب تتحدث عن رقعه كبيره
من المباني المتضرره في كل المنطقه الشمال
السوري مناطق سيطره المعارضه ووصولها الى
اكثر من 140
كيف تبدو
الامكانيات هذه الساعه خاصه بان ايضا
تركيا هي متضرر كبير وهي نقطه او مركز
الزلزال كيف يمكن توسيع العمل على الاغاثه
وانتشال المزيد من
العالقين تحت الانقاض
نحن في مؤسسه في المؤسسه
اعلنا ان شمال غرب منطقه منكوبه غير
قادرين الى الان بهذه الامكانيه الاستجابه
لكل هذا الابنيه المدوره المدمره نحتاج
المساعده من الجميع نحتاج المساعده في
كافه الاصعب وكافه وكافه المجالات لكي
نستجيب وننقذ اهلنا ونقدم الرعايه الطبيه
والصحيه عشرات
الى الان الى الان لم يتم التواصل مع اي
جهه ممكن ممكن يكون في يحدث تواصل بالوقت
القريب
الى ان هذه الصور التي نشاهدها اذا من
سرمدا وهي تظهر يعني امتداد
لدمار كبير لحقه بمجموعه كبيره كتله كبيره
من المباني وواضح بان عمليات الانقاذ
والاغاثه هي مستمره
تتزامن هذه الكارثه هذا الزلزال وتبعاته
مع احوال جويه التي تقوم او تواجه كل هذا
الكم من الدمار وهذا ما يدفعني سؤال السيد
اسماعيل ما اهم ما تحتاجونه الان بشكل
عاجل انتم كمنظمات مدنيه في الدفاع المدني
نحن بحاجه كما ترى الصوره ابنيه عدد
الابنيه كم الدمار كم الركام الموجود وحجم
المعدات الموجوده لدينا لغير كافي لكي
نستجيب وهذه الحاله الموجوده التي تشاهدون
في سرمده هي حاله من عشرات الحالات في
الاتارب وفي ادلب وفي قرى اخرى لذلك نحن
بحاجه لمعدات بحاجه كما
قلت بحاجه في جميع المجالات الطبيه
والمعدات وفي لاستقبال اهالينا الذي
الذين خرجوا من بيوتهم بسبب زلزال هناك
عوائل الان بيوتهم تضررت بهذا بسبب
الزلزال لا يمكن ان يعودوا ان يعيشوا في
هذه المنازل يحتاجون الى ماوى يحتاجون الى
رعايه طبيه يحتاجون الى اي كل شيء لحتى
يتعاون من هذه الصدمه